ich finde es toll dass man sich dank dem
internet so ziemlich alles selbst
beibringen kann und in der digitalen
welt ist das schon echt dame aber mit
einem 3d drucker damit kann man die
realität erschaffen indem ich kenne mich
jetzt in 3d drucker bestellt übel viel
werkzeug und wird jetzt versuchen den
nächsten titel sponsor finden also alle
noch nicht da gewesenes spielzeug
konzipieren aber auch hier in meinen
eigenen momenten produktion netz das ist
mit abstand mein ftx das projekt des
experimentes zwei wochen hier und ich
habe mittlerweile ein patent dafür
angenehm ok ich will noch nicht zu viel
sagen findet irgendwas in dem video
beschreibung irgendwas krasses aber
schaut und erstes und damit ich mal ein
bisschen planer was aktuell so am
spielzeugmarkt abgeht na ich weiß was
ich seit über zehn jahren schon immer
gemacht habe und zwar in einem spielzeug
kataloge nachschauen sehr viel mit
elektronik das werde ich aber nicht
machen ich will etwas jünger sind das
ist genial ist viele puppen und modelle
ist auch cool aber ich will alles was
sich bewegt ich will eine rechtliche
action drin haben bauklötze sind
natürlich auch sparen aber ich glaube
ich war schon welche richtung es geht
ich will irgendwas simples irgendwas
mechanisches was sich bewegt oder dreht
oder springt oder fliegt und ich hätte
schon gerne was mit dem man immer besser
werden kann wie zum beispiel jojo eben
magneten sind cool magneten sind richtig
cool ich schreibe alles auf was mich
inspiriert anstatt gedanklich vor einer
leeren wand mit unbegrenzten
möglichkeiten zu stehen definiere ich
schon jetzt welche art von funktionen
und materialien mein spielzeug haben
soll entlang dieser einschränkungen wird
es mir dann hoffentlich leichter fallen
kreativ zu werden
diese materialien ermöglichen setzt auf
jeden fall viel spaß und lustige
bewegungen und sehr viele möglichkeiten
mit den dingen zu interagieren das sind
es aber natürlich nur kleinere teile für
die mechanik der hauptbestandteil wir
natürlich aus plastik im 3d drucker
schafft der 3d drucker ist auch schon
bestellt und unterwegs aber bevor es
dann an den druck und an die anfertigung
geht müssen wir natürlich erst mal in 3d
modelle von herrn schaffen und dafür
natürlich erstmal ein fertiges konzept
und jetzt jetzt richtig krass ich nehme
euch erstmal ein bisschen zum
ausprobieren mit dem eine virtuelle
werkstatt ja ich habe schon recht ich
könnte mir jetzt geht es dann auf papier
oder am tablet machten aber glaubt mir
das hier wird jetzt definitiv zehnmal
cooler also was ich jetzt machen kann
ist nämlich übel insane und zwar kann
ich jetzt hier einmal einfach so einen
würfel zeichnen den eher hoch zimmern
dann seht ihr den zum kaiser wird es
natürlich zeitlos machen jetzt mal ein
paar sachen ein spieler mit drohungen
von jojo ist auch total zeitloses
probleme an den juristen
nur komme auf die idee ich würde ihnen
das was man halt irgendwann bei dem das
mit dem man besser werden kann pro
person handle wollschläger boing boing
boing so dass hier nach oben
schon aber ein sandwich mit ein paar
sprung fehlen dazwischen wo man quasi
das hier so nach unten drücken kann dann
hakt sich das ding hier in diesem haken
zu 1 und dann wenn man diesen hebel
leben drückt dann wird der hier
freigelassen und sich die sprungfedern
bio weiß auch nicht wie man das noch ein
spielzeug bringen kann aber ich mach
einfach drauflos und lass meine fantasie
entscheiden doch egal was ich entwerfe
eine idee bleibt hängen magnete
schlussendlich basieren meine drei
lieblings entwürfe darauf dass sich
magneten anziehen können aber nicht ganz
berühren sie also quasi schwebend 3d
drucker sind angekommen ich bin mega
aufgeregt so das ist mégane als mein
gott wo polizei alles klar technik was
genau auch hier ist also ich habe jetzt
in 3d drucker der steht da wie lege ich
jetzt los dass ball musst du ja da ein
3d modell erstellen dann könnte es jetzt
nicht einfach so dinge in die luft rein
drucken a schade dafür gibt es die
funktion das aufstützen gedruckt wird
aber im idealfall solltest du immer
versuchen oft stützen so weit es die zu
verzichten also keine überhänge hingegen
ja genau in seinem neuesten video
auftakt hat er übrigens sowas wie ne
railgun gebaut natürlich nicht wirklich
denn das wäre illegal
ansonsten einfach irgendwo dem modell
und einen die drucker software
reinschmeißen und das war es dann schon
oder genau relativ leicht an
gerade die auf jeden fall mit pl das ist
wesentlich einfacher ja beispiel abs
witzig abs ist der kunststoff aus dem
lego männchen und playmobil männchen
bestehen ja cool alles ja einlegen und
viel glück so ich habe jetzt hier am pc
quasi dieses dieser sandra dem modell
kunstmesse geht rein also speichern wir
das mal zur hand geklappt ich würde
sagen let's go problem das mal so hier
soll usb sticks zum allerersten mal
drücke ich jetzt war es um das erste
werden wie zusammen sein wie gesagt habe
ich gar kein fan ich habe das gefühl für
drei sekunden ausgepackt wie es besser
geht rein mein böser und jetzt ein wolf
drucken ist das jetzt echt so leicht ich
weiß auch gar nicht groß das ist dann
wird das jetzt kann ich wollte einen
minimarkt kein also ich weiss mini
machen damit auch mega schnell fertig
gedruckt ist
[Musik]
so mein allererster 3d druck ist fertig
wir schauen mal rein
ob das was geworden ist wohin sie sich
richtig cool aus es sieht richtig kohle
raus
ok ich musste mal raus der klebt ein
bisschen am boden fest muss ich schon
sagen
jetzt kann sie abbrechen ich weiß nicht
ob der prozess so klien war von mir aber
wer tatsächlich und erste 3d modell und
ich finde es super gut geworden es ist
richtig richtig schön geworden ich habe
auf der ungenauen einstellungsstopp
überhaupt gemacht und das ist es einmal
richtig gut geworden wie krass ist das
dann einfach aus dem nichts so ein
richtiges ding zu erschaffen krank also
ich glaube dass wir für unser spielzeug
das heißt die gröbste einstellung ich
mache jetzt mal nur so zum spaß die
feinste
[Musik]
das bisasam ist zwar schon echt cool
aber 3d druck kann auch viel mehr um die
grenzen zu testen probiere ich es mal
mit einer deutlich komplexer kann
vorlage die bereits auf meinem rucker
gespeichert war und drucke sie über
nacht
was ist das denn eine sehr sehr riesig
der ist ja riesig challenge ist immer
dieses ding auch darunter zu kriegen ich
glaube immer irgendwas falsch ich glaube
da kann ich mir irgendwas immer ein
prozess zu verbessern
aber er ist ja übelkeit also ich glaube
uns entwickelt nicht so viele grenzen
gesetzt und damit zurück zu meinem
eigenen spielzeug um diesen ersten
prototypen zu drucken brauche ich
natürlich erst mal 3d modelle davon also
auf geht's damit die halterung für die
magneten auch die richtigen maße hat
messe ich diese ab mit meiner digitalen
schieblehre die auf einen hundertstel
millimeter genau misst 1 6 auf 2,7
millimeter dann gehe ich in 3 d programm
und erstelle eine torpedo ähnliche form
mit einer böse auf der einen seite in
die später eine schnur kommt und eine 6
x 27 mm einlassungen auf der anderen
seite für den magnet
[Musik]
okay das war jetzt der grosse druck den
ich bisher gemacht habe
das ist weil sie jetzt das hauptstück
von meinem ersten spielzeit prototyp
sehr nahe ist hier zum ersten mal
richtig ticken support war es hier und
hier sollte jetzt der magnetisierung
posten steckt doch ganz drin
okay die halterung stimmen das gerüst
stimmt wir sagen ich bringe jetzt mal
schön zusammen dafür haben wir erst mal
hier in schweden zuletzt dabei soll
jetzt sein dass diese beiden magneten
sich quasi eigentlich nie berührt aber
sich mal berühren wollen dass wir jetzt
mühseliger prozess funktioniert das
schon geil das ist schon richtig geil
die magneten die berühren sie nicht aber
die geschrieben und wenn ich jetzt hier
so macht dann disconnect und wir kriegen
das hin dass diese beiden sachen sich
aber mal so berühren es gibt einen weg
aber das über schwierig wenn ich jetzt
dafür sorge dass ich das hier quasi im
zentrum halte und ich dann quasi nur den
hier so nach oben schwingt dann müsst
ihr nun aber das ist ja mal viel zu
krank weil es erstmals namen hast dann
ist zeit lebt nicht mehr so einfach
die zusammen zu bekommen und ist schon
wie so ein spiel soll ich mich ehrlich
sage ja also ich habe jetzt auch halte
ich für eine woche sehen kriegt habe
eben nicht das ding ist jetzt also wenn
man trinkt kriegen würde dann würde ich
das spielzeug durchgehen lassen
doch ein bisschen zu schwierig wir
müssen so weitermachen kann wie ich von
ihr eine idee
du weißt du was cool wäre wenn diese
hier an dieser achse nach so drehen
würden wohl wenn ich wenn ich ein
kugellager rein machen würde
oh/da angelagert dann würden die sich
nämlich auch stimmen die ganze verhasste
smart was lernen wir aus dem ersten
prototypen da sich die magneten sonst
ständig verheddern probieren wir's mal
mit kugellagern damit das spiel spaß
nicht ständig gebremst wird also erstmal
kugellager vermessen damit sich die
schnüre länger machen kann um den magnet
besser schwingen zu können mache ich die
gabel ein stück weit breiter und zur
stabilität auch ein stück dicker
desweiteren mache ich diesmal alles
modular sollte ein teil also nicht
passen und umgestaltet werden müssen
spare ich so zeit und muss nicht alles
noch mal drucken es ist schon wieder mit
der nacht also stelle ich den drucker an
und falle erschöpft ins bett
[Musik]
ich kann's kaum erwarten das neue ding
jetzt mal anzuschauen wir haben hier
verschiedene sachen wir haben jetzt
zweimal diese gabelung einmal waagrecht
und ein mal senkrecht gedruckt dann habe
ich auch den griff den ich freunden so
gedruckt habe jetzt auch einmal denkt
gleich gedruckt und man sieht es ja
schon sehr sehr deutlich ja bei je
nachdem wie hoch man quasi den
druckereien stellt sehen dann auch die
einzelnen sachen anders aus ich komme
hier ist wegen kleines kind wenn man die
sache so pflücken kann ok hier macht man
das noch ab die support strukturen
man schaue sich jetzt an sich euroshop
sogar im internet bewährt
und ich habe ich jetzt mehr kassen
walter kommen hier so ein loch hat wo
immer das drin ist und kann ist voll
schwer mit einem messer raus titeln sie
quasi so eine frau die einfach die
ministerin sein kann anderem schraub
haken und dann kann das einfach so mit
rausnehmen ohne probleme
[Musik]
doch die werden jetzt noch tricky diese
aussparungen hier mega sale die dinge
hier sollte ich eigentlich hier drauf
stecken können das problem ist nur dass
ich hier nicht das support material ab
gemacht hat sondern den steck kopf
selber jetzt muss ich die beiden teile
kurzem neu drucken
[Musik]
hier einmal alle bauteile
der moment der wahrheit passt jetzt auch
wirklich alles okay versuche man das
hier das haar das sieht so gut aus
ja das sieht aus als wäre es aus einem
teil das ist richtig gut geworden
herumhängt gott sagt das sitzt auch hier
oben drauf kommen jetzt die kugellager
die beiden teile sind auffällig steckt
jetzt ein bisschen zu lang und dick aber
mit ein bisschen nachhilfe geklappt so
dass wir das richtig lustig ja okay das
geht auch um das hier geht auch darauf
dann muss aber ebenfalls klebt dann netz
kleben aber ich glaube dass wir jetzt
eine unterlage fängt ja schon mal gut an
broadcom 4 4 aus das ist es jetzt muss
nur noch hier der faden gespannt werden
mit magneten klasse ganze aber vorerst
anhalten so es ist ausgeartet
hoffentlich das ist echt schon so ein
kleiner kindheitstraum einmal sein
eigenes spielzeug ein paar cent jetzt
muss nur noch hier der faden gespannt
werden mit magneten
[Musik]
die beiden hätten sie jetzt quasi nicht
gerührt und sie auch nicht es sieht aus
als wenn sie schweben mal schauen ob man
damit spielt kann man heute spaß macht
und als allererstes das korrekte ich war
erstmal okay wird die kugellager ist
aber deutlich besser weil sie sich nicht
mehr ständig verändern also meine taktik
die beiden zum berühren zu bringen ist
es zb den oberen hier möglichst konstant
zu lassen und dann hier so den unteren
hoch springen zu lassen quasi dass der
hier möglichst fix ist und ich mit dem
ihr schwung aufnehmen und der hier dann
so hoch flippt sodann so dass wir noch
gehen dass man die beiden dinge mit
ihren connected
was also beide müssen sich berühren ohne
dass du berührst ist ja irgendwie eine
bewegung hinkriegen dass sie sich beide
in die mitte bewegen
ja es ist eine bewegung kommt man mal
probieren
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
was lernen wir aus diesen fällen ein
kugellager aufsatz etwas enger
kugellager halter in die gabel mit
integrieren
mit der gabel breiter machen für mehr
stabilität wir zeigen euch übrigens hier
nicht den ganzen optimierungsprozess
denn das spielzeug muss immer wieder neu
gedruckt zusammengebaut und getestet
werden nur um dann festzustellen dass
eine kleinigkeit immer noch nicht ganz
perfekt ist weil ich anscheinend nicht
genug kleber benutzt habe lässt sich ein
plastikteil und ja also noch mal neu
[Musik]
ich habe ein wirklich gutes dann kriegst
du auch sein dass jedes mal muss man
erst mal trainieren das warum noch
bessere materialien wie eine bessere ich
nur wer schon nice sogar soweit okay so
und das ziel ist die zusammen zu
bekommen und jetzt hast du dir selbst
konzipierten das hast du nicht ok go man
muss ja gesagt ich wollte eigentlich
bewusst versuchen die ungleich wie sich
drehen zu lassen wie es würdest du als
hättest du gerade über das heißt es im
handel du willst zu löschen
die habe ich das nie geschafft dieses
links sowie legt dann bewegen sich die
ihr gleichzeitig will man es offen ist
okay einmal noch
dass das böse erschaffen so dass das
böse erschaffen ich will das nicht
wahllos schafft wirklich einfach in same
wenn ihr das jetzt auch leisten könnte
das ist jetzt wirklich das wildeste was
ich bin und was wir hier jemals besucht
haben ich hab ein patentanwalt bezahlt
für über 3.000 wir haben uns die
markenrechte mac flip hier sicher ist
und welche die alle hebel in bewegung
gesetzt um das ding zu produzieren mehr
ich damit gespielt habe und ich meinen
freunden gezeigt habe desto geiler finde
ich die idee dass ein echter macht jeder
abend könnte ich habe auch mittlerweile
in rebeccas gefunden ich es immer
schafft aber fast ihr macht also es gibt
ja noch ein paar tricks damit zum
beispiel den hier
es geht auf verschiedene art und weisen
wie zum beispiel das hier ist das
leichteste wenn ihr uns jetzt bei der
größten schnapsidee des jahrtausends
unterstützt vermischt wird dieses ding
tatsächlich aber für jeden verfügbar zu
machen dann können dann selbst über den
link in der video beschreibung
unterstützen und euch jetzt 1 bestehen
auf kickstarter ich habe jetzt
mittlerweile ungefähr schon 5000 euro
drin investiert also ein drucker
patentamt material alles mögliche um das
einmal realisieren fehlt aber noch
einiges das ist verdammt teuer anwälte
sind teuer patent ist teuer das teil zu
produzieren ist teuer in deutschland
hand arbeitsprozess bild euer letztes
ziel 15.000 euro zusammen und zwar
spendet ihr da nicht sondern ihr könnt
euch das ding jetzt schon bestellen
könnt uns jetzt mit 24 euro unterstützen
und bekommt zum teil schon da sind preis
nicht über gedrückt habe ich dachte
ursprünglich dass wir verlust machen
wenn wir es für unter 50 euro verkaufen
weil im handball 3d drucker und und wenn
die 15.000 euro dann noch bis ende
januar zu stande kommt dann produktion
wir das teil ansonsten ist natürlich
kein risiko für euch wenn es nicht
zustande kommt aber wenn es zustande
kommt dann produzieren wir das teil wir
haben schon 29 euro hält er hat das denn
gemacht ich hab noch nirgendwo
veröffentlicht wir haben jetzt über
nacht schon zwei unterstützer ich nehme
es gar drei tage auf bevor das video nun
kommt er für acht euro kriegt eine
namentliche nennung in einem der
nächsten updates videos auf youtube wie
ich das machen werde und er kriegt er
stilisierte hübsche blaupause von dem
jetzt im download als wallpaper für 24
euro kriegt ihr das teil nach hause
geschrieben zusätzlich zur namentlichen
nennung und dem wallpaper für 49 euro
kriegt ihr zwei davon flossen entstand
fuß den ich jetzt moment wertes
namentliche nennung und so weiter und
sofort für 99 euro und ich weiß dass es
fehlt das ist er für leute die wirklich
kann glauben und komplett bock drauf an
dafür bekommt er nicht nur zweimal den
sondern auch einen limitierten in gold
fonds handsigniert und eine ausgedruckte
handset blaupause von dem teil mit einem
kleinen dankeschön drauf geschrieben und
die höchste stufe ich empfinde 52 heißt
investor keine ahnung wieso jemand so
viel rein hauen wollen würde also ja
wenn er meine verrücktesten brown bisher
unterstützen wollt oder auch so ein fall
haben möchte und verschiedene tricks
lehren wollen damit ja es gibt so krasse
sachen die man damit machen kann und
nicht wenn es mega geil wenn sie die
leute dann wird die das teil einmal dran
haben selber tricks ausdenken lassen und
die auch irgendwie nach sich selber
benennen oder keine ahnung aber jeden
fall wenn ihr möchtet dass diese
komplette schnapsidee und dieses
luftschloss einfach realität werden seid
dabei legen die beschreibung das video
in dem ich das ding meiner familie zeige
und die das ist ein bisschen
ausprobieren das geht auf meine zweite
kanal wenn ich jetzt ein bisschen mehr
action von sehen möchte wie das
komplette anfänger sehen und auch was
meine eltern zu sagen dass ich einfach
ein patent für das klingt link zum
schicksal da ist auch eine beschreibung
und sehen uns nächstes jahr wieder
ich hoffe er hatte vor weihnachten und
ich wünsche euch ein wunderschönes jahr
2021 kann ja fast nicht vorstellen dass
das was wir weil mich dumm ist das denn
eigentlich aber ich hab doch
[Musik]